bonjour à tous bienvenue le plaisir de
vous retrouver cette semaine avec
philippe juvin pour vous faire un point
de l'actualité nationale internationale
et je vais donc commencer par la vie de
notre mouvement et l'agenda l'agenda
c'est donc aujourd'hui un déplacement de
notre président dans le département du
val de marne à saint maur des fossés
cet après midi commencera par une table
ronde sur le thème du sport
puis aura une réunion du bureau de la
fédération du val de marne et enfin à
18h30 une réunion militante à la salle
des fêtes de l'hôtel de ville demain il
n'y aura pas donc de bureau politique
mercredi un déplacement du président en
inde
il sera accompagné d'eric woerth notre
secrétaire général et de luc chatel
président du conseil national
ce déplacement en inde vous l'imaginez
bien est un déplacement important
il commencera par un dépôt de gerbe en
hommage à gandhi
puis le président sarkozy s'entretiendra
avec l'ancien premier ministre indien
avant une rencontre économique organisé
par la chambre de commerce franco
indienne il déjeunera ensuite au
ministère des affaires étrangères puis
aura une audience avec l'actuel premier
ministre de la république de l'inde et
enfin rencontrera les républicains de
l'inde en fin de journée un point
maintenant si vous le voulez bien sûr
nos adhérents je voudrais vous rappeler
que depuis le 1er janvier 2016 le parti
des républicains enregistré après
constat d'huissier effectué le vendredi
8 avril 76 1757 nouveaux adhérents
contre 75 1920 l'an dernier à la même
date donc une progression parmi ces
nouveaux adhérents il est intéressant de
souligner que près de 10 mille d'entre
eux n'avaient jamais adhéré vous n'avez
pas renouveler leur adhésion depuis plus
de deux ans
par ailleurs le nombre de renouvelant
s'établit à 58 1396 contre 55 1366 à la
même date l'année dernière
les républicains se félicite donc de la
stabilité de la croissance des primes
aux adhérents par rapport à 2015 ainsi
que de la croissance du nombre de
renouvellement qui s'élève donc à 5%
avec un total à l'heure actuelle de 248
1562 adhérents statutaires et au vu de
la dynamique de la croissance d'adhésion
le party les républicains s'impose donc
comme première force militante et
politique de france un autre point
peut-être sur les investitures au cas où
cela a réchappé à certains d'entre vous
vous l'avez compris le président sarkozy
souhaite faire de la place des femmes en
politique une priorité et la parité
n'est donc pas un vain mot puisque dès
qu'il est possible de le faire au niveau
des investitures
le parti investit des femmes c'est donc
le cas dans les alpes-maritimes pour
remplacer christian estrosi dans la 5e
circonscription c'est marine brenier qui
à 29 ans qui a été investie cette
semaine elle est adjointe au maire de
nice conseillère départementale des
alpes-maritimes et c'est la présidente
des jeunes républicains donc un beau
symbole pour les femmes
un beau symbole pour les jeunes avec
cette investiture de martin grenier
pardo marine bruni c'est bien vous
suivez c'est un test
un petit point sur l'actualité politique
française avant de laisser la parole à
philippe juvin qui rentrera plus en
détails donc sur l'actualité européenne
et internationale
vous l'avez tous constater puisque vous
êtes des observateurs de la vie
politique
mais la situation à gauche et
particulièrement agitée en tout cas
cette semaine nous avons eu le droit à
un nouvel épisode assez intéressant cela
commence évidemment
par une gauche qui est dispersée divisé
et j'ai comme image presque l'impression
que cette gauche se trouve dans une
lessiveuse et qu'elle va sortir pour le
moins 20 c voire et sort et de ce qui
est en train de se passer
qu'en est il exactement nous avons
président de la république qui est
complètement discrédité comme jamais ça
ne s'est passé sous la vème république
un président dont 8 français sur 10 ne
veulent plus oui on sait sur dix ce
président a par ailleurs un gouvernement
affaibli
affaibli par la politique qu'il mène
avec l'abandon du texte sur la déchéance
de la nationalité
et que voit-on en ce moment avec le
projet de loi elle connerie c'est que ce
projet de loi elle conneries à sortir un
tri j'espère que tout le monde sait ce
que veut dire la tri mais pour ceux qui
ne rêvent pas franc comtois dans cette
assemblée un tri c'est quelque chose qui
est diminuée qui ratatine est une sorte
de vieilles gloires flipper il n'en
reste plus grand chose
eh bien c'est ce qu'est devenu le projet
de loi elle commence par ailleurs alors
là se lassent not least un ministre
lance son propre parti politique
at on jamais vu ça un ministre qui lance
son propre parti politique sous l'oeil
protecteur apparemment du président de
la république mais plutôt un oeil
courroucé et le regard fâché du premier
ministre ambiance enfin comment aussi ne
pas s'étonner que des mouvements
contestataires soient issus de cette
propre majorité de gauche
c'est la première fois là aussi que l'on
assiste à ce la nuit debout ou les
mouvements lycéens
ce sont des mouvements issus de la
gauche de cette gauche plurielle qui ne
sait plus en effet où elle habite
donc nous sommes ici dans une situation
à nulle autre pareille avec donc une
ambiance délétère
non seulement plus haut niveau de l'état
au sein même du gouvernement
et au niveau social
cette désespérance que l'on retrouve
dans ce mouvement
entre autres de nuit debout nuit debout
qui est la conséquence de l'incurie de
monsieur hollande de ses mensonges nuit
debout c'est monsieur hollande qui l'a
créé lui debout c'est la déception
c'est la déception entre autres de la
jeunesse mais c'est la déception aussi
de bien d'autres militants qui ne savent
plus vers qui se tourner et comment
trouver un moment pour se faire entendre
nous voulons aussi bien sûr si nous
pouvons comprendre la déception de ceux
qui s'expriment
nous voulons d'abord condamné la les
années tout ce qui a été fait au niveau
des violences dans les environs de cette
place de la république
que ce soit au niveau des magasins mais
peut-être avoir une pensée pour le
commissariat du xième arrondissement
ce commissariat dont vous savez et
partis sont partis les premiers
policiers au moment des attentats du 13
novembre alors que donc que des
centaines de personnes squattent la
place de la république où j'ai cru
comprendre ce matin qu'il y avait enfin
peut-être un mouvement de la part du
gouvernement pour évacuer nous
condamnons évidemment donc les
dégradations ces dégradations qui comme
le rappelait hier valérie pécresse sont
à hauteur de 500000 euros et nous
attendons donc du gouvernement qu'il
prenne ses responsabilités et que les
mesures nécessaires à l'ordre public
soit enfin prise au nom de quoi en effet
ce sitting serait-il maintenu quand une
manifestation sur voie publique et j'en
parle en tant qu'élu local en tant que
maire d'arrondissement où il n'y a pas
un carnaval d'enfants une brocante qu'on
autorise sans qu'on vérifie en amour
s'il n'ya pas trouble à l'ordre public
y aurait-il deux poids deux mesures dans
ce pays
entre ceux qui font des sittings et ceux
qui essayent de contribuer à la vie
locale d'un territoire
deux poids deux mesures qui ne sont pas
acceptables
enfin comment aussi ne pas s'étonner
que cette place de la république qui est
un lieu de mémoire collective un lieu de
recueillement en mémoire des victimes
des attentats soient ainsi les s'est
dégradée abîmé et qui en fait tout
simplement avec des personnes qui
manquent de respect je parlais de du
climat à gauche
peut-être un mot sur les primaires ces
primaires à gauche qui sont voulus par
64 64 % des français c'est déjà beaucoup
qui souhaite donc qu'il y ait une
primaire pour désigner le futur candidat
aux présidentielles de 2017
mais vous l'aurez constaté c'est loin
d'être fait même si les socialistes ce
week-end lors de leur congrès ont trouvé
le moyen de voter une motion validant la
tenue de ces primaires pour le moins
surprenant sachant que c'est plus humain
était déjà inscrite dans les statuts de
leurs mouvements ils ont dû quand même
revoter et puis comment ne pas s'étonner
qu'ils aient besoin d'en reparler
puisque le président hollande lui même
en 2011 lors d'une interview rappelé son
souhait en effet de primaire pour le
président sortant
alors est ce qu'on est en train
d'essayer et d'amuser la galerie
est ce qu'on est en train d'essayer de
remplir l'espace médiatique
est ce qu'on est en train en effet de
vouloir nous enfumer car ces primaires
auraient-elles juste pour mission de
renforcer le candidat hollande qui vous
l'aurez bien compris il n'a plus aucune
légitimité et qu'elle primaire lorsque
l'on sait que les verts ne savent pas
encore s'ils vont y participer
lorsque l'on sait que le front de gauche
a déjà dit non lorsque l'on sait que le
mrc a dit non lorsque l'on sait que npa
a dit non et que lutte ouvrière aussi
alors vers quel primaire allons-nous
c'est donc pour nous un écran de fumée
qui est là juste pour le cacher le
discrédit de monsieur hollande et les
nous étonnons aussi car je pense que
c'est un cas unique qu'un président
sortant ne soit tout simplement pas le
candidat naturel de son propre parti
enfin peut-être un mot
re ministre qui aime bien faire parler
d'elle mais là en ce moment c'est pas sa
séquence si je puis dire madame royal
madame royal a fait de son comme image
pourrais je dire
là aussi l'occupation médiatique le coup
de com elle est familière de cela et
elle avait parlé au moment où elle avait
gagné la région poitou charentes qu'elle
allait faire de cette région un
laboratoire un laboratoire dont on peut
se réjouir aujourd'hui qui n'est jamais
vu le jour au niveau national
puisqu'elle voulait faire de ce
laboratoire la même chose pour la france
et comme le disait tout à l'heure
philippe c'est un laboratoire qu'elle a
partagée avec françois hollande car les
échecs de madame royal en région poitou
charentes et bien ce laboratoire nous
l'avons connue j'allais dire par
personne interposée
au niveau national je vous rappelle
quand même d'ailleurs que françois
hollande n'avait rien trouvé de mieux
que de nommer madame royal à la tête de
la banque publique d'investissement
quand par ailleurs elle et c'est une
région avec des entreprises exemple qui
n'était même pas payer pour des
prestations qu'ils avaient effectué pour
la région que direz peut-être il n'est
pas inutile là de le rappeler de son
positionnement sur l'écotaxe sur son
revirement sur le fait que la résilier
le contrat déco mauvais que cela aura
coûté en pénalités 800 millions d'euros
à l'état avec rappelons le des portiques
qui sont en train de moisir sur les
autoroutes de france mais avec peut-être
une différence en région ile de france
grâce à valérie pécresse
je referme la parenthèse mais quelle est
cette désinvolture de madame royal
à quel moment peut-on encore pensé au
moment où il ya le discrédit des
politiques que c'est en toute impunité
on peut continuer d'être ministre après
avoir laissé une région en dans un tel
état dans un état en fait de faillite
eh bien nous posons la question est ce
que madame royal a encore toute sa place
au sein de son gouvernement au vu de ce
que nous apprenons jour après jour
faudrait-il des lanceurs d'alert aussi
pour les élus régionaux ou les élus qui
ne tiennent pas leur parole on peut se
poser la question
enfin peut-être un petit mot sur le
chouchou des médias puisque c'est comme
ça que vous l'appelez entre vous
emmanuel macron alors monsieur macron
est en marche
il est en marche il est en marche vers
où il est en marche avec qui il est en
marche pour quoi faire
alors j'ai suivi son intervention
télévisée
et vous avez dû être nombreux à le faire
et bien je vous le dis j'ai été très
déçu car aucune révélation si ce n'est
qu'il a confirmé ses aspirations
libérales qui sont vous en conviendrez
toujours autant incompatible avec la
gauche archaïque à laquelle il
appartient c'est à dire ce gouvernement
qui se plaît qui se complaît dans un
immobilisme total
alors pour que sa démarche apparaissent
parfaitement sincère
il ne lui reste à mon avis que d'une
seule chose à faire c'est quitter le
gouvernement
c'est donc démissionner il ne peut pas
d'un côté dénoncé les blocages qui
minent la société et de l'autre est un
rouage de celui qui les produit c'est
juste une question de cohérence
dans le cas contraire le soupçon
consistant à le présenter comme le
poisson pilote de françois hollande en
vue de 2016 2017 se vérifierait son
initiative serait pour le moins
disqualifiés puisque toutes les
personnes qui ont cru en lui et en sa
sincérité serait pour le moins déçu il
se veut en homme libre il lui appartient
à lui maintenant de nous le prouver
car la question reste tout entier repose
et chantre du mouvement ou agent
électoral d'un françois hollande à bout
de souffle la question donc à mérite une
réponse
et bien après vous avoir fait ce petit
tour d'horizon de politique intérieure
je passe la parole à philippe juvin qui
va lui s'exprimer sur la politique
européenne et internationale
merci un point d'avoir sur macro pour
compléter si tu me permets il ya une
chose qui ne faut pas oublier c'est que
ma cran pendant deux ans et demi
emmanuel macron quelles que soient ses
qualités qui sont probablement grande
était le principal conseiller économique
du président de la république et donc
les cinquante et quelques milliards de
prélèvements supplémentaires et donc la
fameuse taxe les 75% et donc la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires c'est macron c'est pas
une décision qui vient de nulle part il
était le conseiller économique du
président de la république et donc il
est intéressant de voir qu'aujourd'hui
il prend une posture libéral mais il est
à l'origine des décisions probablement
les pires qui ont plombé le le
quinquennat de françoise alors sur les
questions européennes
quelques points à à traiter d'abord je
pense que vous seriez déçu si je ne
parlais pas du 850 deuxième épisode du
pnr qui peut-être va prendre fin cette
semaine puisque je vous parle nous
sommes lundi matin tout à l'heure j'irai
à strasbourg le parlement européen siège
en session à strasbourg pendant les
trois jours qui viennent et nous avons
de bonnes raisons de penser que le pnr
va être adopté par le parlement européen
enfin durant cette session paulo mardi
au mercredi
pourquoi croyons nous que cela va être
le cas d'abord parce que le ppe mais les
républicains au sein du ppe ont été
comme vous le savez depuis l'origine en
faveur du pnr contre l'avis du front
national qui a été constamment contre le
pnr contre l'avis des socialistes
français au sein des socialistes
européens
et là nous pensons que nous allons
pouvoir réussir à faire voter le pnr
pour d'abord une raison
conjoncturel c'est que les attentats de
bruxelles au fait bouger les lignes en
tout cas chez les libéraux et chez les
verts les libéraux et les verts sont
dirigés au parlement européen par les
belges verhofstadt
pour les libéraux lambertz pour les
verts est très clairement on a senti
dans ces deux groupes une modification
d'attitude vis-à-vis du pnr donc nous
pensons que le pnr devra être adoptée
enfin lors de cette session il ya deux
personnes qui ont été extrêmement
importante à la manoeuvre au parlement
dans cette affaire ce sont deux français
c'est rachida dati et brice hortefeux
qui sont membres d'une commission qui
est la commission des libertés
le petit bémol c'est que les socialistes
expriment leur volonté de voter le pnr
encore à une condition donc ce n'est pas
encore gagné
ce soir il ya un vote à la commission
libe commission des libertés au niveau
local qui consiste à mettre au vote une
directive sur la protection des données
individuelles et cette directive devrait
être votée et dans cette hypothèse même
les socialistes ont dit qu'ils
voteraient donc je crois que premier
ministre valls devrait passer à
strasbourg demain ou après demain
qu'elle l'a annoncé pour montrer son
soutien c'est un peu comme les
carabiniers il arrivé après la bataille
en disant regardez gras savoye ça va se
faire en fait c'est pas grâce à lui
c'est contre et malgré l'avis de tous
ses alliés depuis les mois qu'on
travaille qu'on bataille donc a priori
je ne devrait plus avoir beaucoup à vous
parler du pnr dans les semaines qui
deuxième point concerne la turquie
jouets revenir sur l'accord que l'union
européenne à vote a assigné le conseil
avec les turcs c'est qu'il ya un accord
politique au niveau du conseil chef
d'état d'exécutif que nous avons
contesté parce que nous avons considéré
que monsieur erdogan
en réalité nous humilier dans cet accord
est acheté notre lâcheté collective et
les choses ne sont pas terminées
pourquoi parce que nous avons découvert
il ya quatre jours un texte que là je
vais j'ai sous les yeux je tiens à votre
disposition qui est une motion pour une
résolution qui va être soumis au vote du
parlement européen et qui reprend donc
le vote devrait avoir lieu mercredi ou
jeudi
les éléments de l'accord politique
survenue au conseil donc on retrouve
l'accord du un pour un
l'accord de la turquie qui s'engagent à
nous aider et on retrouve des éléments
qui avait été passé sous silence au
moment du conseil et ses éléments posent
un véritable problème politique et nous
demandons au président de la république
de s'opposer en tout cas nous voterons
contre les éléments que je vais vous
citer de s'opposer à cet accord est
manifestement françois hollande en douce
à accepter cet accord il ya trois points
qui nous paraît scandaleux et donc il ya
un point qui est connu malheureusement
que nous avons contesté dès le début
c'est l'ouverture du chapitre 23 et 24
sur les sur les négociations d'adhésion
ils figurent dans ce document c'est sans
surprise mais nous votre rencontre et
république à votre encontre
avant je suis à deux autres items dont
peut-être vous n'avez pas entendu parler
en tout cas qui sont restés bien caché
c'est que il est d'abord dit que dans le
chapitre 52 de ce texte que le turc
deviendrait une langue officielle de
l'union avec à 24 25 langues officielles
dans l'union européenne
et bien c'est quelque chose d'absolument
ahurissant
manifestement les chefs d'exécutifs donc
le président de la république lui-même
ont accepté ce principe que le turc
alors que la turquie est loin d'être
membre heureusement de l'union
européenne le turc deviendrait une
langue officielle de l'union nous allons
nous opposer évidemment à ce point
j'espère que nous aurons que nous
gagnerons le vote les en tout cas que
l'exécutif et accepter ça nous paraît
absolument abracadabrantesque le
deuxième point qui nous paraît
absolument scandaleux et contre laquelle
nous allons voter aussi c'est qu'il ait
dit quelque chose d'exorbitant c'est que
il est affirmé dans le paragraphe 7 de
ce texte que quand les ministres pour le
conseil des ministres des affaires
étrangères de l'union se réunira et bien
il accueillera en son sein le ministre
des affaires étrangères turc ce qui est
quelque chose qui ne s'est jamais vu
quand on discute avec les américains on
n'invite pas le ministre des affaires
étrangères américain en conclave avec
les ministres des affaires étrangères
européens
c'est
l'europe a des intérêts à défendre et on
ne discute pas des intérêts de l'europe
à défendre en présence de la partie
adverse
même si la partie adverse évidemment est
une partie avec laquelle il faut obtenir
un accord et donc nous trouvons ces deux
points ne turc qui entre qui entrerait
comme langue officielle de l'union et le
fait dans les cas où la turquie serait
impliqué de permettre aux ministres des
affaires étrangères turc de faire partie
du conseil des ministres affaires
étrangères nous paraît quelque chose
d'ahurissant et nous demandons
officiellement et solennellement
président de la république de dénoncer
ces deux parties de l'accord voilà ce
qui arrive quand le président de la
république française et silencieux dans
ces conseils parce que ni vous ni moi
sommes présents à ces conseils il ya
suffisamment de témoignages de gens qui
assistent depuis maintenant trois ans ou
quatre ans qui peuvent témoigner du fait
que françois hollande arrive à ses
conseils non préparée avec la
chancelière
ce qui n'était pas le cas auparavant le
président français l'a précisé la
chancelière
arrivé en préparant les choses les
choses ne sont pas préparés et en plus
le président république reste silencieux
ne défend pas ses deux aspects
troisième point concernant les affaires
européennes je voudrais revenir sur la
sphère de panama alors on en a beaucoup
parlé vous avez évidemment commenté avec
raison ce scandale
nous voulons dire la chose très simple
c'est que si il ya aujourd'hui très peu
de paradis fiscaux en fait si la sphère
de padam açores c'est qu'il ya plus de
panama il ya quasiment plus de paradis
fiscaux et je veux rappeler à ce que la
mémoire courte que le fait qu'il n'y a
plus de paradis fiscaux c'est parce
qu'en 2009
un président de la république française
a mis le holà et à l' ocde ou g20 puis l
ocde a exigé que ce soit la fin des
paradis fiscaux
c'est à partir de 2009 car ils étaient
les relancer une procédure extrêmement
dur qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a
guère plus que le panama a peut-être une
ou deux îles vierges caïman qui sont
encore des paradis fiscaux est par
exemple n'y a plus de paradis fiscal en
europe il ya plus de secret bancaire en
suisse il ya plus de secret bancaire en
belgique et plus de secret bancaire au
luxembourg
et bien tout ça c'est la conséquence du
travail fait depuis 2009 parce que j'ai
entendu les critiques comme d'habitude
un peu folle qui consiste à dire oui
c'est sous la présidence sarkozy que le
panama a été sorti de la liste noire
tout ça est une caricature puisque c'est
nous qui avons mis fin à l' os à ce
principe du paradis fiscal et si en 2012
le panama était sorti de la liste noire
c'est pas que c'est la france qui l'a
sorti ce sont 12 des principaux pays
glossées 2 qui ont sorti le panama ça a
été une décision collégiale parce que le
panama à l'époque avaient signé des
accords langage est il se trouve qu'en
2013 2014 et 2015
le panama n'a pas respecté ces accords
et donc il aurait été logique alors que
les états qui avait signé en 2012
dénonce r d nous ressert le le set
ces conventions fiscales les états n'ont
pas fait pourtant 2015 la commission
européenne j'ai vérifié dans les petits
papiers
la commission européenne a attiré
l'attention des états européens en
disant attention pas damas ne reste
respecte pas ses engagements 2012 mais
sur les états il faut réagir et la
réaction des français a été très clair
puisque le sas février 2016 monsieur
sapin à féliciter a félicité le ministre
affaires étrangères panaméen des grandes
avancées qui avait eu lieu dans sa lutte
contre le blanchiment
donc on voit qu'on est quand même dans
une attitude qui est tout à fait
incroyable ou en 2009 il ya une
processeur process du procès ce qui est
lancé
grâce à la france et aux états unis à
l'époque cela conduit en 2012 à une
signature d'une convention fiscale qui
finalement n'est pas appliquée par le
panama et bien on ne fait rien on laisse
la convention doit être appliquée
quatrième point sur un anniversaire
c'est aujourd'hui qu'a sorti hier
l'anniversaire du vote d'une loi en
italie qui est une loi qui s'appelle le
job act alors on dirait que jo bats et
patrese italien mais c'est comme ça que
les italiens ont appelé leurs lois y
compris un nom anglais qu'est ce que
cette job act italien on peut dire pour
aller très simple que c'était une loi m
comrie avant détricotage est encore
meilleur et grâce à cette job act et
bien les italiens ont créé en fait des
dispositions de contrat de travail
qui ont poussé environ trois cent
soixante mille contrats précaires à
devenir des coûts des cdi et il ya une
baisse du chômage en un an
en italie il y à une diminution du
nombre d'emplois précaires il ya une
augmentation du nombre d'emplois nettes
et ça c'est parce qu' un gouvernement en
l'occurrence socialiste qui aurait dit
socialiste qui a eu le courage de faire
ce que ici nous n'avons toujours pas le
courage de faire et les faits s'est vu
au bout d'un an
et bien évidemment matteo renzi a été
très très critiqué à l'époque par sa
majorité même exactement comme en france
et lui a tenu bon l'ue a fait ce qu'il
fallait
aujourd'hui l'italie en bénéficient
d'italie voit son nombre de chômeurs pc
alors que nous nous augmentons jours à
l'appel de plus de mille chômeurs tous
les jours en moyenne depuis le début du
quinquennat
enfin dernier point je voulais évoquer
avec vous peut-être de 2,2 points
rapides
eurostar vous savez qui est la grande
machinerie un statistique européenne a
publié les statistiques de commerce
extérieur de l'union et eurostar a
publié que depuis 2002 la chine a doublé
sa part dans le commerce extérieur
européen autrement dit aujourd'hui des
européens d'abord commerces
essentiellement avec l'europe ça c'est
connu mais quand ils commercent avec
d'autres comme d'autres partenaires que
l'europe il
il vend des antennes essentiellement aux
usa mais surtout ils achètent enchaîné
20% des achats des pays européens en
dehors de l'union viennent de chine est
donc ce point est évidemment clé parce
que c'est un vin pur sang qui est en
plus dynamique et qui va monter donc
cela renforce la volonté des
républicains d'appeler à ce que nous
appelons maintenant depuis un certain
nombre de mois et d'années à ce que
l'europe se dote d'un outil douaniers
tels qu'ils nous permettent de lutter
efficacement contre une concurrence
déloyale
qu'elles soient sociales ou
environnementales 20% des importations
européennes sont désormais chinoises
c'est énorme et je pense que nous devons
absolument savoir nous protéger quand
cela est nécessaire et enfin peut-être
dernier point qui est un point très
européen vous allez dire mais qui en
même temps témoigne de la disparition de
la france de la scène européenne en
matière diplomatique
en 91 les trois ministres français
allemand et polonais s'étaient du mas st
gall cher avait créé ce qu'on appelle le
triangle de weimar le triangle de weimar
c'était en fait une unité trois grands
pays -france continentaux france
allemagne pologne pour jouer ensemble en
matière diplomatique et peser dans les
décisions qui seraient prises par
l'union
il se trouve que la semaine dernière le
nouveau ministre polonais des affaires
étrangères witold waszczykowski dont je
vous appellerai le nom si vous le
souhaitez à proposer au ministre
allemand des affaires étrangères est
très curieusement non pas au ministre
française et étrangère mais à l'ancien
ministre français des affaires
étrangères qui l'a interrogé fabius pour
des raisons qu'on n'a pas bien compris
je pense qu'il ne sait pas que le
ministre des affaires étrangères
français a changé c'est tout à fait
authentique et fabius a répondu que pour
lui il n'était pas nécessaire de
relancer ce triangle de weimar et
passifs abuse on a averti son successeur
et il est extrêmement fâcheux que la
france décide comme ça sur quelles bases
l'on discuté d'abandonner un outil
diplomatique qui avait bien servi durant
les vingt dernières années quand il a
fallu il avait fallu accompagner
l'élargissement de l'europe aujourd'hui
la pologne
ça va être un pays qui a fait de grands
progrès économiques qui compte
à l'est en la question ukrainiennes et
russes la pologne est évidemment un
partenaire fondamental et nous
regrettons républicain encore une fois
une sorte d'amateurisme qui fait que la
france spontanément comme ça parce
qu'elle l'a décidé sur quelle base
décide de se priver d'une arme
diplomatique bien bien utile pourtant
voilà sur les éléments européens et nous
avons donc nous sommes à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
franco european au haut de la liste
elle est juste rajouter quelque chose
parce que je voulais quand même aussi
vous faire un point car je suis un petit
peu étonné on l'a constaté encore samedi
sur le terrain ou même ici à lors de la
rencontre avec notre président qui
accueillait les nouveaux adhérents sur
ce que sont les primaires a
chez les républicains les plus chers de
la droite et du centre
je voudrais rappeler quelques règles
parce que trop de candidatures font qu'
il y à du flou chez chez les français et
même chez nos adhérents
toute candidature bien sûr et
respectable c'est il faut s'en réjouir
puisque c'est le principe même des
primaires mais il faut rappeler que
toutes les personnes à l'heure actuelle
ne sont candidats qu'à la candidature il
faut le rappeler
lorsque les gens dit je vais voter untel
ou untel ils ne pourront voter que
lorsque tout cela aura été validé donc
je rappelle quand même à tout le monde
les modalités et le calendrier
le calendrier ça sera vous le savez un
dépôt de candidature officielle le 8
septembre et pour cela pour être
candidat il faut le parrainage de 20
parlementaires de 250 élus issus de
trente départements différents et 2500
adhérents
ça n'est pas rien c'est sont les
conditions pour participer aux primaires
qui elles n'ont pas commencé
contrairement à ce que certains essayent
de faire croire
les primaires ne commenceront que
lorsque les candidats auront donc pu
donner tous ces éléments et donc après
le dépôt 'l'annonce des candidats après
vérification du dépôt de leurs
parrainages orale donc lieu le 21
septembre
c'est seulement le 21 septembre que nous
connaîtrons les candidats à la primaire
et je vous rappelle le premier tour et
le 20 novembre et le deuxième tour le 27
novembre
voilà paraît important que tout le monde
est bien en tête que pour l'instant les
primaires les vraies élections n'ont pas
commencé et que nous n'avons là pour
l'instant que des candidats à la
candidature
ça me paraît nécessaire de le rappeler
parce que en tant qu'élu terrain je suis
assailli d'inquiétude d'interrogation et
je profite de ce moment pour le signaler
à tout le monde
merci